bonjour antoine alors cela a été annoncé
samedi les autorités russes vont
entreprendre une campagne de vaccination
massive comme en comptait s'y prendre et
bien l'institut qui a mise au point le
vaccin travaille d'ores et déjà avec
trois laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui
se prépare à produire ces vaccins en
série difficile à ce stade de dire
exactement dans quel volume mais d'après
les premières projections dévoilé par le
ministre de l'industrie et du commerce
il sera possible de produire plusieurs
centaines de milliers de doses par mois
avant la fin de l'année avec la capacité
de passer à plusieurs millions de doses
d'ici le début de l'année 2021 et il en
faudra à des doses le 1er août le
ministre de la santé annonçait que les
premiers groupes de population allaient
commencer à être vaccinés à partir du
mois d'octobre
je vous propose d'écouter sur ce sujet
le directeur de l'institut où se sont
déroulés les essais cliniques
la vaccination sera volontaire tout
d'abord le vaccin sera appliquée est
proposé aux personnes qui font partie
des groupes à risque
il s'agit bien sûr de médecins qui
peuvent toujours être infectées et dont
l'immunité est vitale à la fois pour
sauver leur propre vie en évitant d'être
infecté par les patients et pour
protéger les autres patients contre
l'infection ou alors il pourra s'agir de
diplomates de personnes dont les
professions implique des déplacements
constants et des contacts avec beaucoup
de gens se seront les premiers groupes à
être vaccinés et je crois que de
nombreuses personnes accepteront
volontairement de participer d'abord à
des essais puis à la vaccination
volontaire et la procédure
d'enregistrement de ce vaccin suit son
cours d'ici une dizaine de jours sa mise
sur le marché devrait être validé par
les autorités sanitaires
sachant qu'un deuxième vaccin développé
par un autre laboratoire va suivre
quelques semaines plus tard il faut
savoir que plus de 100 vaccins sont
actuellement en cours de développement à
travers le monde et il est clair que les
premiers vaccins fiable efficace à être
mis sur le marché
partiront avec un avantage certain sur
la concurrence
merci antoine pour toutes ces précisions